I always found it very stressful to live
in big cities in Kew I can go to work
within five minutes by bike
my name is Jing mango I come from China
I'm 27 years old and I'm an
astrophysicist I work at the University
of Q Germany is very good for scientists
is a very efficient country
everything is aware of nice and people
know quite clearly what they are
supposed to do in their jobs
money
right now I'm studying the relation on
the surface of my outside it is very
important to understand Martian
environment in order to prepare for
human nation and also to learn about if
Mars could or could ever sustain life or
not we have a parka detector on both of
a rover which can move on the surface of
Mars it's like a moving laboratory
although that I'm just doing a small
part of a big project still a few very
proud of this work and I hope that one
day human landing on Mars is going to be
possible
international collaboration is really
one of the exciting things in science
because you get to learn the most
innovative technology from another
country I really love doing science
sometimes difficult to debug if you are
so much into your code into your program
there's a ping-pong table down the
cellar you know Institute sometimes I
let my program run for half an hour and
just go down late to play ping Kong and
when I come back I had my date already
okay my boss didn't know that I know he
knows I like calligraphy and I started
doing it when I was 10 years old
it requires one to concentrate and relax
at the same time it's like a kind of
meditation but it's it's fun
learning is fascinating if I could learn
on my life that would be fabulous I
would like to teach in the future
because I think it's very important to
let the public know about science
you